ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY'S TUESDAY FEBRUARY
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE WILL OPERATE AS A
SUB COMMITTEE WE HAVE.
TWO ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TO BE
HEARD TO RESOLUTIONS AND ONE
BILL THAT IS ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT AGENDA.
SO WILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
TWO. SCR SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR
JACKSON.
AND MY CHAIR LEFT TO RIGHT.
THAT'S.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PERCENT SCR
SEVENTY EIGHT.
THIS IS.
SOMETIMES KNOWN AS THE CEDAW
BILL WHICH CALLS FOR THE
COMMISSION.
OF FOR THE ELIMINATION OF
DISCRIMINATION ACTUALLY THE
CONVENTION I BELIEVE IT IS FOR
THE ELIMINATION OF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN.
S. MEASURE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THERE IS A CONTINUED NEED.
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PROTECT THE HUMAN RIGHTS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN TO ANALYZE
THE OPERATIONS OF STATE
DEPARTMENT'S POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS.
TO IDENTIFY DISCRIMINATION.
AND IF IT IS IDENTIFIED TO
REMEDY THAT DISCRIMINATION.
THIS MEASURE URGES THE STATE TO
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PRINCIPLES UNDERLYING SEA DOT.
THIS WAS SET UP.
A MEASURE THAT FIRST WAS
INTRODUCED BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. KNOWN AS THE
INTERNATIONAL BILL OF RIGHTS FOR
WOMEN. IT IS THE FIRST AND ONLY
INTERNATIONAL INSTRUMENT THE
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSES
WOMEN'S RIGHTS WITHIN POLITICAL
CULTURAL ECONOMIC
SOCIAL. AND FAMILY LIFE AND
SINCE EVERY COUNTRY IS
DIFFERENT.
SEE DAHLE PROVIDES A A A
GENERALIZED BLUEPRINT.
FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO OVERCOME
THE REMAINING BARRIERS OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT EXIST.
IN VARIOUS COUNTRIES ARE IN THE
WORLD THAT IT DEFINES WHAT
CONSTITUTES DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN. AND SETS UP AN
AGENDA FOR NATIONAL ACTION TO
END THAT DISCRIMINATION.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IS ONE OF ONLY SEVEN NATIONS
THAT HAVE NOT RATIFIED THIS
INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENT.
WHICH IS VITAL HAS PROVEN VITAL
TO ADDRESSING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN AND GIRLS.
I WANNA LISTS THIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS STARTLED ME
FOR QUITE SOME TIME ONE OF
SEVEN.
THE OTHER SIX.
THE PACIFIC ISLAND NATIONS OF
TONGA IN PALAU.
THE VATICAN IRAN.
SOMALIA.
IN THE SUDAN.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S A NATIONAL
LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO EQUAL
RIGHTS FOR WOMEN THERE IS STILL
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL. WOMEN CONTINUE
TO BE PAID LESS THAN MEN ACROSS
VIRTUALLY ALL OCCUPATION
CATEGORIES.
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN THE
SYSTEMIC.
THE RAPE CULTURE CONTINUES TO
PERVADE LIVES OF WOMEN OF ALL
AGES.
AND THE RIGHT TO LIVE WITH
DIGNITY.
FREEDOM FROM SHAME OR FEAR
CONTINUES TO BE COMPROMISED.
THIS RESOLUTION PASSED THE
SENATE FLOOR WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IT'S A MEASURE THAT I HAVE
BROUGHT.
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES WITH
REGULARITY IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL
IF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
JOINT MOST OF THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT PREPARED TO
DO THAT AND I WOULD SUSPECT IN
TODAY'S WORLD WE ARE EVEN
FARTHER AWAY FROM IT THAT WE
WERE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US AS ONE
OF THE LEADERS.
TO ENDORSE THIS EFFORT AND TO
SUPPORT IT
AND I HAVE. WITH ME TODAY MY A
PRINCIPAL CHO AUTHOR WHO
REPRESENTS THE US CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
HAS TAKEN THE LEAD IN THIS
EFFORT AND IS IN FACT.
BEEN WORKING TO IDENTIFY THOSE
AREAS WHERE THERE IS. OF THIS
INEQUITY.
I HE WILL SPEAK AND THEN.
WE HAVE TODAY ELIZABETH NEWMAN
WORKPLACE POLICY AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S DEPARTMENT.
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN TO SAY A
FEW WORDS IN ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
THANK YOU FIRST WE'RE GONNA
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM
HERE CHAO.
YOU HEAR.
BONTA.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN. GRACE.
THANK IT WE DO OF COURSE.
TO TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND.
TO OUR GOOD SENATOR AND ARE.
SENATE CHAIR COLLEAGUE.
THANK YOU FOR.
HELPING TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
I AM A PRINCE WILL CO AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE IN PART BECAUSE
LAST YEAR I WAS ASKED BY WOMEN
LEADERS IN MY CITY TO MOVE. THIS
RESOLUTION FORD SAN FRANCISCO
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A POWER IT
LEADER IN WOMEN'S EMPOWERMENT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT OUR CITY
BECAME THE FIRST CITY IN THE
WORLD TO ENACT A LOCAL ORDINANCE
THAT REFLECTED THE PRINCIPLES OF
CIDA. AND A FEW YEARS AGO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ARE THE LATE
MAYOR MAYOR LEE LAUNCHED A
CAMPAIGN CALLED CITIES PROCEED
OFF. A AUTHORING A RESOLUTION
WHICH WAS ADOPTED UNANIMOUSLY BY
THE US CONFERENCE OF MAYORS THE
CHALLENGE MAYORS OF OTHER CITIES
TO ENACT MEASURES SIMILAR TO THE
C. DAHLE ORDINANCE THAT WE HAVE
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
TO DATE OVER SIXTY CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND OUR COUNTRY HAVE
FOLLOWED SUIT. A I ALSO. NOTE
WHEN WE STARTED TO RESEARCH ON
THIS WE REALIZED HOW MUCH
LEADERSHIP ARE ARE.
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY HAD LET ON THAT SO I
APPROACHED HER AND.
AND SHE WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE YOUR DECADES LONG FIGHT
IN THIS AND I AM HAPPY TO BE
ALONG FOR THE RIDE.
BUT I JUST WANNA ALSO NOTE THAT
WE STARTED THIS CONVERSATION.
BEFORE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
BEFORE ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE ARISEN IN RECENT MONTHS BUT
I CAN'T IMAGINE A MORE TIMELY
RESOLUTION FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD. ARE AT THIS MOMENT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AS A
STATE TO CONTINUE TO BE A BEACON
OF HOPE ON THESE ISSUES. AYE AS
WAS MENTIONED BY.
CHAIRWOMAN.
HANNAH BETH JACKSON THE FACT
THAT THE FEW JURISDICTIONS
AROUND THE WORLD THAT HAVE NOT
RATIFIED THIS ARE ARE THE ONES
THAT THEY ARE NOT WE ARE NOT IN
GOOD COMPANY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO GET OFF THAT LIST GET
ONTO THE RIGHT LIST AND
CONTINUE.
TO SHOW OUR LEADERSHIP NOT JUST
AS A STATE BUT AS A COUNTRY.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING I'M
ELIZABETH NEWMAN FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN I'M CIDA IS NOT
JUST ABOUT NAMING EQUAL RIGHTS
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS IT PROVIDES
A FRAMEWORK TO. IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS INEQUALITY AND SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND SAN
FRANCISCO CEDAW HAS PUSHED
GREATER INTERAGENCY PARTNERSHIPS
AND IMPROVE PUBLIC SERVICES IN
SAN FRANCISCO. IT IS A MATTER OF
GOOD GOVERNMENT TO KNOW WHO IS
BEING SERVED AND HOW WELL THEY
ARE BEING SERVED.
WE HAVE MONITORED THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF COMMISSIONERS
AND BOARD MEMBERS AND SAN
OF POLITICAL OPPORTUNITIES. AND
AFTER A DECADE OF REPORTS WOMEN
ARE NOW HALF OF APPOINTEES.
A BUT WHITE MEN ARE STILL
OVERREPRESENTED AND ASIAN AND
LATINO ACTS MEN AND WOMEN ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED. WHEN THE CITY
AND COUNTY FACED A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE. A GENDER
ANALYSIS OF BUDGET CUTS BY CITY
DEPARTMENTS IDENTIFIED THE
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT ON WOMEN
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR. A
IN THE PROPOSED LAYOFFS AND
REDUCTION OF SERVICES.
MORE THAN A DECADE OF INTENSE
FOCUS ON POLICY REFORMS CROSS
AGENCY COLLABORATION AND
EXPANDING DIRECT SERVICES TO
SURVIVORS LEAD TO A RECORD FORTY
FOUR MONTHS WITHOUT A SINGLE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOMICIDE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE SEE TOUGH FRAMEWORK HAS
BROUGHT TOGETHER POLICE OFFICERS
ANTI DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ADVOCATES
JUDGES AND DEPARTMENT HEADS TO
SAVE WOMEN'S LIVES.
THERE ARE MANY AREAS OF WOMEN'S
GIRLS LIVES WHERE DESPITE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS EQUALITY IS
NOT A REALITY.
BUT WITH THIS FRAMEWORK AND
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF OUR
SUCCESSES WOMEN AND GIRLS
TAXPAYERS AND POLICY MAKERS HAVE
ALL. BEEN BETTER SERVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO BECAUSE OF CIDA.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD ENSURE
THAT THE STATE NOT ONLY SUPPORTS
THE RIGHT OF WOMEN TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN POLITICAL AND
PUBLIC LIFE THE RIGHT OF
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT HEALTH.
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL BENEFITS BUT
IT ALSO COMMITS TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF CIDA BY COLLECTING
DATA MONITORING PROGRESS. AND
INFORMING POLICIES TO BETTER
SERVE ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
IT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMON.
ISRAEL.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU.
.
MADAM CHAIR.
AND MY COLLEAGUE FOR PRESENTING
THIS I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO SHED LIGHT WHEN WE HAVE THE
INEQUITIES THAT WE HAVE THE. THE
THE ELECT INEQUALITIES TO SHED
LIGHT I APPRECIATE THAT THE
SUPPORT.
SEVERANCE CISCO'S VERY WELL
REPRESENTED THERE.
BOB I'M SURE THAT OTHER CITIES.
THAT NEED TO STEP UP TO THAT BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
RIGHT A THE QUESTIONS COME.
SINGER CENTER YOU MAKE LOVE IT'S
THANK YOU AND.
I DO APPRECIATE THE REFERENCE
TO. A THE EMERGENCE OF VARIOUS
MOVEMENTS INCLUDING ME TO WHICH.
EXPRESS THE FRUSTRATION ABOUT
WOMEN BEING TREATED. UNEQUALLY I
THINK A LOT OF THIS IS PERHAPS A
UNDER THE RADAR IS NOT
CONSCIOUSLY INTENDED.
THE PURPOSE OF SITAR IS TO BRING
TO THE FORE. OF THE VARIOUS
ISSUES THE VARIOUS BUDGET
INEQUITIES THE VARIOUS
CONSEQUENCES ALL OF THE KINDS
OF.
PERHAPS UNINTENDED UNCONSCIOUS
BIASES THAT EXISTS SO I DON'T
LOOK AT THIS IS.
FINGER POINTING ANYWHERE THIS IS
AN ATTEMPT TO GET INFORMATION SO
THAT WE CAN REDRESS AND SOLVE
THESE INEQUITIES THAT ARE.
PROBABLY IS SOLD THIS TIME AND.
I THINK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE OF.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I THINK THE
PEOPLE OF SAN FRANCISCO
DEMONSTRATED THAT YOU CAN'T FIX
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW WAS WRONG.
AND THIS IS A MEASURE TO PUT A
MAGNIFYING GLASS TO VARIOUS
TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
WHERE THERE'S NO ASSUMPTION THAT
THERE IS ANYTHING WRONG EXCEPT
FOR EXAMPLE WE SEE THE HIGH
LEVEL OF HOMICIDES THAT HAVE
EXISTED AND I IN RELATIONSHIP
VIOLENCE WORDS WOMEN WHO ARE
PREDOMINANTLY THE VICTIMS?
AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS WORST THE
FUNDING COMING FROM WHERE'S THE
FUNDING GOING IS IT MEETING THE
NEEDS TO WE HAVE FULL
REPRESENTATION AT THE TABLE. SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE A MORE EQUAL
WORLD.
THE CONVENTION ON THE
ELIMINATION OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN IS DESIGNED FOR
JUST THAT PURPOSE
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOST IN ITS THAT THIS
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED KALRA
PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHIU AYE CHIU AYE
BONTA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY I'D. AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES I.
THANK YOU THAT IS ADULTS.
LIKE BRINGS A CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER ONE.
HR SIXTY NINE.
MS CARILLO.
AND WHILE SHE'S COMING UP.
I TAKE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
TO HAVE A MOTION AND.
THE SECOND.
DID THIS IS CONCERNED AS
AMENDED.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHOW CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE BONTA.
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT FILL THIS OUT THAT IS AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SPELL.
MORNING WAS CARILLO.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
A GOOD MORNING HAVE MEMBERS AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM PRESENTING
HR SIX MINUS REPOSE TO BE
AMENDED IN ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
ENSURE WE HEAR THIS RESOLUTION
TODAY. ON THE EVE OF THE
ASSEMBLY DELEGATION STRIPS TO
ALL SALVADORAN.
I HOPE WE CAN NO THE RESOLUTION
FORWARD AND DELIVER A RESOUNDING
MESSAGE OF SUPPORT TO THE
SALVADOREAN REPRESENTATIVES ARE
DELEGATION WILL BE MEETING WITH
TOMORROW AND THE DAYS TO COME.
THAT'S AMENDED HR SIX NINE WILL
NOT ONLY CALL FOR THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO REVERSE
HIS VERY MISGUIDED DECISION TO
TERMINATE THE TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS. ALSO KNOWN US
TPS.
OF SALVADORIAN SEEKING REFUGE IN
THE UNITED STATES BUT IT ALSO
URGES THE PRESIDENT AND CONGRESS
TO FIND A LEGISLATIVE PATH.
TO PERMANENT LEGAL STATUS
FOR THE SALVADORAN.
THE A TPS DESIGNATION FOR
SALVADORIAN AS WAS ORIGINALLY
EXTENDED IN TWO THOUSAND ONE BY
PRESIDENT. GEORGE W. BUSH THE
DESIGNATION HAS BEEN
CONTINUOUSLY RENEWED BY BOTH
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONS AND RECOGNITION.
OF THE DIRE CONDITIONS THE
SALVADORANS FACED BACK HOME.
SALVADORIAN SO WITH TPS HAVE
LIVED AND WORKED IN THIS COUNTRY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE THEY ARE
PARENTS TO APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND. US
BORN CHILDREN WHO HAVE GROWN UP
CALLING THIS COUNTRY HOME.
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WILL BE
TORN APART. BY THIS SENSELESS
UNNECESSARY ACTION.
CALIFORNIA ITSELF IS HOME TO
FORTY NINE THOUSAND SALVADORANS
PROTECTED BY TPS AND AS THE ONLY
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE FROM
EL SALVADOR.
I UNDERSTAND THEIR PLIGHT.
QUITE PERSONALLY. AND CAN
ASSURE YOU THESE PEOPLE ARE HARD
WORKING DETERMINE AND PRODUCTIVE
PRESENCE IN OUR STATE.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THIS
POPULATION AS AN ACTOR PART OF
OUR WORK FORCE AND A QUARTER OF
THEM PAY MORTGAGES.
IF THEY ARE REMOVED OR FORCED
INTO HIDING IT WILL BE A
DEVASTATING BLOW.
TO THE PRINCIPLES OF LIBERTY AND
FREEDOM THIS COUNTRY STANDS FOR.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION HERE
WITH ME AT THE TABLE TODAY IS
CHRISTOPHER GALIANO WHO IS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION
POLICY CENTER. AND CHRISTOPHER
SANCHEZ WHO IS WHAT CHAIR LET
THE COALITION OF HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
BECKY FIRST WITH THIS PLACE
NOBODY MEMBER I CHAIR MEMBERS
CUTS FOR SPONSORS WITH CHAIR OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS WE STRONGLY
STAND SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
AND OFF FOR SEVERAL REASONS. AS
AYE AYE MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF
THE NATIONAL TPS ALLIANCE WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WITH MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
IN THE U. S. SENATE.
SENSE I WE'VE HEARD TALKS ABOUT
THE REMOVAL FOR TPS STATUS FOR A
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES INCLUDING
ALL SALVADORAN. HOW WE KNOW THAT
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE GPS ARE
BENEFICIARIES ARE ARE PEOPLE
THAT GO THROUGH EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND ARMED BE
FOR THE PURPOSE THAT EVERY TIME
THEY HAVE TO? RENEW THEIR TPS
THAT IS RECONSIDERED ITS NOT
JUST READ GRANTED TO THEM SO
THAT IS I WANT ONE REASON THOUGH
AMONG THE ARE MANY REASONS. BUT
ARM ABSOLUTELY ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS
RESOLUTION IN ADDITION TO SEND A
STRONG
ASSETS TO. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A PATHWAY OB FOR RESIDENCY
CITIZENSHIP OP FOR THE THIS
POPULATION.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT IT'S FOR
CHRISTOPHER GONNA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHAIR LEFT.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
LIVED IN THE U. S. I'VE
DESIGNATED GPS DATA SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE AS THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN STATED THAT CONTRIBUTED
MILLIONS TO THE ECONOMY. AND
THEY'VE RAISED A FAMILY CHILDREN
LOTS OF MANY OR WHO ARE ALL US
CITIZENS THAT CHILDREN. ARM IT
WAS A CRUEL HEARTLESS DECISION
TO END TPS.
IT LEAVES A LOT OF FAMILIES.
IN UNCERTAINTY AND AND LIVING
WITH ANXIETY AND FEAR AS WELL.
AND SO WAS MY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
AND AIR CHAIR SUPPORT AS WELL
IN THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND WHAT ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NOT A BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE SYRIANA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. IT IT
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND.
S. OTHERWISE UNINTERESTING
COUNTRY ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRAVEL THERE AND IN.
THE REASON THAT SO MANY OF
SALVADORANS ARE HERE IS BECAUSE
OF THE DANGER THAT HAD BEEN
THERE IN THAT COUNTRY AND AND
SOME OF IT STILL REMAINS.
BUT WHEN I WAS THERE UNDER THE
SORT AND ADMINISTRATION THAT HAD
THE CHANCE TO GO SEE SOME
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK THERE TRYING
TO DO. AND SOME OF THE WORK THAT
IS BEING DONE IN THEIR INNER
CITIES OF THE MORE DANGEROUS
PLACES. AND THEIR SCHOOLS THERE
WERE THAT HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF COMMUNITY AND PARENT.
INVOLVEMENT.
AND THAT THOSE CONNECTIONS THAT
THEY'RE BUILDING IN THERE.
MORE DIFFICULT AREAS IN THEIR
CITIES ARE REALLY STARTING TO
CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE THERE
SO FOR THIS COUNTRY TO REMOVE
TPS STATUS FOR EL SALVADORANS
IT.
AS THEY'RE TRYING TO.
ADDRESS THE ISSUES IN THEIR OWN
COUNTRY I THINK IS A VERY
CYNICAL AND AND WRONG HEADED
MOVE WE WE SHOULD ACTUALLY BE
SUPPORTING THAT COUNTRY.
AS THE UNITED STATES IN ORDER
TO.
TURN IT AROUND
ADDRESS THE VIOLENCE ADDRESSTHE
POVERTY ADDRESS THE REAL NEEDS
THAT ARE THERE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION THE CARTER
ADMINSTRATION THAT. UNDER US
AROUND HAS BEEN REALLY TRYING TO
DO THAT.
IN A STRONG WAY BUT THIS COUNTRY
HAS NOT PARTNERED WITH THEM IN
ANY SIGNIFICANT MANNER WHEN WHEN
THIS IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY I
THINK THAT THAT HAS BEEN MISSED
AND NOW EXACERBATED BY REMOVING.
GODDESS
SO THIS IS A GOOD MESSAGE FOR US
CALIFORNIA HAS
QUITE A NUMBER OF THE EL
SALVADORANS LIVING IN.
IN CALIFORNIA SAID THIS IS A
RELEVANT.
ISSUE FOR US TO BE ADDRESSING
GIVEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF OF OUR
STATE AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE SO THANKS FOR BRINGING A
FOR.
AND WHAT ELSE LIKE TO.
A COMET.
LIKE YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION SECONDS AT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED.
ENDING FURTHER.
ALRIGHT.
SINGER.
YES IS CREE MIKLOS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I.
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR INDULGING
ME FOR THIS IS ACTUALLY THE
FIRST TIME I PERCENT OF THE NEW
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND SO I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
BUT FEEL QUITE AT HOME AND I
THINK THIS FOR ME IT'S IT'S ALSO
VERY PERSONAL ASPIN SALVADORIAN
AND SHARING SOME OF. THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES THAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT AND HOW MY FAMILY CAME TO
THE UNITED STATES FLEEING THE
CIVIL WAR. AND SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION WHAT DETAINMENT
DEPORTATION LOOKS LIKE WE TALK
ABOUT CONTACTS.
AS TO WHY CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
THE LARGEST SALVADORAN
POPULATION OUTSIDE OF ALL SOLID.
SO THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. OTHER.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHOW. CHOW AYE CHU. CHU AYE
BONTA HOLDEN.
OLD AND I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
GRACE I.
THAT RESOLUTION.
THIS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO LET'S DO IT. WE MISSING ANY
VIDEO.
OKAY.
AND FUND. EITHER OF THEM THE
JACKS OUT.
YEAH THINKS CALTRANS
.
LATER
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
THAT COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS
TODAY AND WE ARE ADJOURNED